The Joe Rogan Experience what is it like
to be you like what is it like to and
then I know you know you've gone through
a lot of [ __ ]
and this latest thing with uh getting
off of the benzodiazepine that to me was
a real shocker because uh first of all I
had no idea that you were taking it and
then to find out that it's that
difficult to get off of and then to hear
from other people that have tried to get
off of it how difficult it is and then
to realize how many people around me
have an issue with that stuff Xanax is a
[ __ ] it and I didn't know what a
[ __ ] it was until I talked to a
friend who is a counselor at a drug
rehab center where he was saying that
that is one of the ways that people get
locked back into drinking and doing
drugs as a psychiatrist will prescribe
Xanax and sober people who get on Xanax
all of a sudden start drinking he said
it's super common he said that it's one
of the most difficult drugs to get off
of he said and this is something that Dr
Carl Hart who's uh I love him to death
he's brilliant he he speaks so openly
and honestly about drugs and you know
this guy's a professor of Columbia he
said that there's two drugs that will
kill you when you get off of them he
goes it's alcohol and benzodiazepine
those are the two that if you just quit
you'll [ __ ] die
and or you wish you would meanwhile
they're handing those things out like
Tic Tacs yeah well they were regarded as
a safe substitute for barbiturates and
you could easily overdose on
barbiturates especially with alcohol
well when did they know when did they
know when was it in the literature the
difficulty of of detoxing yourself from
these
very recently really yeah Jesus Christ
and when did they start being handed out
20 years ago [ __ ]
more so what happened people just stayed
on them
often my I have one good friend that
takes it every day and takes it
oftentimes with alcohol which I know
you're absolutely not supposed to do
there's not a damn thing I can do about
it I this is a friend that I love to
death and I just go I put my hands up
and I go there's nothing I could do
and he's been on it for more than 10
years yeah well I started taking them
because I was Ill yeah you know and it
they helped because I couldn't sleep I
couldn't sleep at all I don't know
I don't know
what I still really don't know what
happened you couldn't sleep and so an
anti-anxiety medication do you think
that any this is the one one of the
things that I want to talk to you about
this is why I brought up the Fame thing
how much of
the pressure of being attacked by all
these different people and having these
um people write these uh horrible
articles about you and I know you read
that stuff which is different from me I
don't read stuff about me and I think
that's helped me tremendously and that
like my gauge of how I deal with people
is like Tucker Carlson doesn't read
things about him either he could dull
you can tell by the way he communicates
he seems free you know there's a burden
that people carry around when they read
things about themselves like Eric
Weinstein has that burden sometimes you
know when people read yeah well part of
the reason so did I read things about me
well yeah but
that wasn't what was stressful exactly
when I first got I've had a history of
depression and that runs in my family
and that's probably stems back for me
right to the time when I was a kid and
and I think when I really got sick in
2016 it was partly a manifestation of
that
but at the time my job was threatened
like actually yeah and my clinical
practice was threatened
and the Canadian Revenue Agency was
after me all at the same time and they
were after me because of a mistake they
made which they admitted three months
later and the college was after me
because of a vindictive client who came
after me with a pack of Lies but because
they were so and basically I
emerged from that unscathed but that was
by no means obvious that that was going
to be the case I was accused of sexual
misconduct and the evidence
when I was dealing with this client I
would turn my wedding ring around
you'd spin it well I play with it right
and that was sexual misconduct yeah well
to her it was a signal of some dark
underlying desire that I wasn't that was
polluting our therapeutic relations I've
been doing that with you the whole
conversation yeah I have this uh silicon
wedding yeah what I'm going to report
I'd report you a few later in there yeah
exactly yes well there you go it's it's
really bad and if there was a college
that governed the behavior reprobates
like you I would definitely report no
don't do that that's terrible stretch it
out no that's Freudian to the extreme
although I don't know what turning it
means how could this stretching a
silicone wedding band be Freudian while
you're putting your finger in the little
hole rubber [ __ ] kind of vaginas are you
dealing with rubber is you know that's
good anyways we don't have to go there
so that was all you had done was turn
play with your wedding ring yeah yeah
and I was really I really helped her a
lot like well so unfortunately when
you're dealing with people that are
extremely troubled oftentimes they look
for external reasons why they're
troubled and they find oppressors well
she was also angry with me because when
all this blew up around me it interfered
with my clinical practice and she had
come to rely on our weekly meetings oh
so she was she was angry about being
abandoned and it was really sad because
I didn't want to abandon my clients but
I had to stop my clinical practice which
was also very upsetting to me because I
had like 20 clients and I knew these
people man like they were I knew these
people yeah you know I'd followed them
through thick and thin and then all of a
sudden so many things piled up around me
that I found when I was in a clinical
session that I was distracted
so you can't be distracted in a clinical
session right and so anyways what
emerged from that and it was in the
middle of the winter and I have seasonal
affective disorder I couldn't sleep
and at all for quite a long time and I
went to my doctor and I said I can't
sleep and he gave me a sleeping
medication and and an anti-anxiety drug
and I took the a little bit of the
anti-anxiety drug and I could sleep and
my life was pretty stressful and I
thought okay I'm much better I'm just
going to leave this be this is working
I'm not going to muck with it because I
could barely go back to work and what
was it a low dose yeah yeah I couldn't
even feel Xanax really so it's just so
it alleviated the anxiety but it didn't
affect your cognitive performance or it
didn't affect the world well it didn't
affect it as much as how sick I was like
that really affected so sick meaning
depressed no no when you say you're sick
no no I uh when it hit
um I if I stood up my blood pressure was
really low if I stood up I'd faint I was
fainting five or six times a day when
are we talking about 2016. okay so this
is when all the pressure from all these
different sources was coming at you yeah
and that was making you sick so it was
changing physically yeah that was part
of it I think I think what it did was it
it stressed me enough so that I was
susceptible more susceptible to whatever
was wrong with me in the first place I
have a lot of immunological problems how
long did it take you to recover from the
Ben those
well when I finally
two years
and I haven't fully recovered but but
also I was also sick no I have my left
hand is quite numb
and was way more numb both my hands both
hands and my feet were like completely
numb and uh I was in like excruciating
pain
for two years like pain at levels that I
didn't even know was possible all the
time or no on occasion no this is one of
the things that was terrible about it is
that it was really really bad in the
morning and what did it start right
after you got off of the Xanax no but it
got way worse
so it just started showing up eventually
yeah and then it started to get worse
about the same time that Tammy went into
the hospital but when because she was
fighting her way through you know
catastrophic cancer at the same time
when this started down so this is
additional stress
yes and that heightened everything well
it didn't it certainly didn't help right
I think it made me again it made me more
susceptible to something that was
already happening
so whatever this illness has that that's
plagued my family my father my
grandfather multiple cousins and and a
lot of immunological problems on my
mother's side too my one I had a cousin
whose daughter died of immunological
problems and same ones that Michaela had
and this is all mitigated somehow or
another by this only eating meat I don't
know it certainly is for Michaela and
for you as well I don't know that for
sure
I know what the diet has done